counsel Coleman cook pitcher counselor
heart their Jack cancer right here chair
counselor gamma yeah oh yeah
Thank You counselor Scots the moment
counselor keen yesterday Thank You
counselor more Pat Moore
most of the moment and I'll see I'm here
picture but I've just joined sorry on
the blade time Thank You Jill that's no
problem at all where we were aware Nick
who's that you had technical issues also
joining us is Estelle our legal officer
Emily democratic services and mister
livingstone Ian Livingstone and Emma
been somewhere so that yes we're on we
should be all here now ok you can use to
this I think if you have any
difficulties afternoon during the
meeting please contact Democratic
services or call and the number today is
his Charlotte who is on five a double 7
193 her number will be included at the
top of the chat stream for your
convenience I would ask participants
when you are not speaking please mute
your microphone to minimize any
background noise why we're going through
our proceedings microphones must only be
on if the participant has been granted
permission to speak to gain permission
to speak please very briefly indicate on
the chat on the right hand side of your
screen and I within make a note and go
back to you once the person speaking has
finished but everyone present please
make sure that mobile phones are turned
silent and they must not make calls or
take calls during this meeting
please also refrain from checking emails
or conduct in any other business and
ensure that you are in a quiet room free
from distractions for the duration of
this meeting please note that this
meeting is being live-streamed for
members of the public and following the
meeting the recording will be available
on the council whistle YouTube channel
members wishing to speak under cancel
procedure 21 is there any member we have
with us this afternoon who wishes to
speak under 20.1 we don't thank you
public speaking the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking
please members take note that agenda
item 4 e d 0 5 you have two members of
public speaking on that item agenda item
1 apologies for absence
we have apologies from councillor Dennis
substituted by councillors SV agenda
item 2 declarations of interest
does anybody have any declarations of
interest thank you agenda item 3 minutes
of the planning committee item 3a
minutes of the planning committee on the
20th of May 20-22 do I have a proposer
and if you're happy with them proposed
seconded check thank you do you all
agree
agreed Thank You members agenda item 3b
minutes of a planning meeting on the 3rd
of June do members agree that these
myths of the committee which was held on
3rd June are full correct do I have a
proposal please
opposed to second it thank you
do you all agree agreed no abstentions
no thank you very much agenda item for
settler planning applications and public
speaking any site visits will take place
when and it is possible when I've mister
livingstone has gone through this this
afternoon
if anybody wasn't here it stays the same
again if possible if there are any site
visits Democratic Services will let us
know how we go about it I'm moving
forward to planning applications
bringing up the agenda item up for a
which is the planning application for
deferral of the orb in 243 Ramsgate Road
Margate I have statements to be read out
and Estella is going to do that kindly
forests and the first speaking is from a
mr. living I hope that is spelt I've
stated that correct who's raising points
of concern that's Dale Thank You
chairman so this is a statement good
afternoon members the application looks
to make productive use of the previously
developed site within the urban area to
make a meaningful contribution towards
the supply and delivery of much-needed
local housing the applicants have also
developed the adjacent site here nine of
the 14 units are occupied by NHS key
workers being ideally located for the
hospital it is anticipated that this
development would serve a similar
function with interest already received
from other key workers keen to secure
accommodation in the area objects
objections received to date on heritage
grounds are all noted and fully
understood it is recognized that the
former public house use and original
building are
historic and as such it is quite right
that the application should consider any
Heritage impacts it is for this reason
that the applicant commissioned a
detailed historic review at the site to
inform the design and consideration of
the application which has been carried
out by Canterbury archaeological trust
whilst the sentiments of the objections
is understandable the facts and evidence
reveal a building which has been
extensively altered over time to the
extent that very little original fabric
all features remain as the council's own
conservation officer concludes having
visited and inspected the site in person
and this is in quotation marks and
fortunately little to none remains of
its character internally with the main
somewhat original that largely replaced
and repaired front facade
sorry Oh Rita again with the main
somewhat original but largely replaced
and repaired front facade resulting in a
feature common and perhaps better
portrayed elsewhere in Margate closing
that Acamas the proposed design will
utilize and incorporate the original
fabric of interest within the new
buildings as shown by the conservation
officers assessment a visit and
inspection of the site clearly reveals
the building's compromised condition and
illustrates the inherent limitations
that would prevent any feasible
conversion given its condition levels
within the building and configuration
this is notwithstanding the odd economic
realities of this and the fact that the
building's position and orientation on
site limit any reasonable opportunity to
build additional units alongside the
existing building while some fortunate
the only viable and feasible option for
the site is redevelopment it is
overwhelmingly evident from the
financial accounts and string of
landlords who have been unable to make
the business profitable despite past
investment that ongoing use as a public
house is enviable this was the case even
before the current Kovach 19
restrictions and difficulties this
presents going forward despite marketing
alternative pub or other commercial user
was identified for the site without a
viable and deliverable redevelopment
scheme the sad reality is that the site
would inevitably continue to remain
vacant and fall further into disrepair
indeed it is noted that commenting
online on a recent press article
regarding the application a former
landlord of the orb confirmed that the
building needed open inverted commas
serious investment which simply is not
worth it and that it is sad to see it go
but it would only sit there rotting if
left close inverted commas the
applicants has worked closely with
officers to develop the design which is
appropriate for the site context
preserves neighboring amenity and
delivers appropriate levels of parking
and open space for residents it is
therefore hoped that members will
support the positive officer
recommendation and secure an active and
beneficial use for the site Thank You
Estelle another letter has been received
and I will ask so to read that house is
from mr. Thompson Thank You chairman
Margate Civic society's objections to
this proposal are extensive and fully
documented within the case officer's
report the society still considers that
the destruction of this well-respected
local landmark should be resisted at all
costs the orb is of considerable
architectural merit and has stood on
this site in its current form for almost
200 years
the report by the Canterbury
archaeological trust submitted by the
applicant even commends the building has
been of local historic interest it is
precise precisely for this reason that
the building should be retained the
society has no objection to the building
being converted and even appropriately
extended to provide residential
accommodation although the building does
not enjoy listed status this should not
affect the desire to retain something of
architectural merit Margate civic
society does therefore urge the Planning
Committee to think very carefully
before agreeing to the loss of this
well-loved local landmark we only get
one chance to save and preserve our
local heritage and here is an
opportunity at this committee meeting to
do just that we do therefore most
respectfully urge the committee to
refuse this application and grant this
building the opportunity for
preservation rather than destruction the
orb cannot plead its own case so on
behalf of the orb Margate Civic Society
urges the committee to refuse this
application and grant this lovely old
building the opportunity to continue
gracing the local landscape thank you
very much Estelle I now ask the officer
to give her report please Thank You Emma
I think we've lost Emma for a moment yes
thank you okay Thank You Gemma so the
application site is outlined in red here
so fronts on to Ramsgate Road you can
see the existing building and towards
the center of the site to the left or
neighborhood properties at front on
Safari Road and then to the right hand
side you can see naturally this is an
aerial view of the application site so
the application site is located front in
the field so fun to run to get growing
up the city fields on the right hand
side of the screen and here is the
active site here so you can see there's
a horse circus over to the front of it
and then the building and behind it and
with maybe poppies over to the left on
the right hand side you can see in this
view is the former petrol station which
was on the adjacent site that these
sites recently been developed for
housing and this is a view taken from
the other side of the road looking
towards it so you can see the front
elevation of the old building towards
the center of the site and then this is
a photo taking eradicate Road looking
towards the application sites you can
see that they're all building facing us
and the right-hand side with a parking
area over to the left and the
neighboring properties in Farley Road in
the distance and then this is inside the
application site so this is the focal
area to the front of the all and again
the neighboring properties in the
distance and then this is the side
elevation of the all building so this
the elevation of fronts round gate road
this is the front elevation of the
building then this is looking again to
the front elevation but then the side
extension to the front of the slide to
the front of the to the side of the
front elevation and then it's the rear
of a bit of the site with the existing
trees along the
three and then this is to the rear of
the orb so and this is the rear
elevation and you can see the extensions
are taken place and to the rear of the
property and then again this is the rear
yard area and you can see the
neighboring properties in the distance
this again is the forecourt looking
towards the neighbors and then again a
closer shot of the neighbors and you can
see the existing boundary wall that runs
between the site and then this is taken
from around the road looking towards the
neighboring adjacent development where
their former petrol station was so you
can see the fact that a 2d three-story
development has been recently
constructed on this site we've also
development to the rear of it and then
this this is looking inside taken from
the orb looking towards enabling
development site so again you just see
and the development next door so the
applicant is the same developer for this
this development and then again you can
see the proximity of the new development
to the orb so this is the existing front
elevation and so the main issues to be
considered through this application is
that the demolition of the building the
loss of the community facility and the
impact on the clarity appearance of the
area from the new development so this is
the existing front elevation and then
you again going back to the existing the
photo of the front elevation so the
Heritage statements been submitted with
the application the building's not
listed it doesn't fall within the
conservation area but the main
consideration is whether it's because it
has been on designated heritage asset so
the heritage statement submitted with
the application and has given some merit
to this front elevation however you can
see that the porch area at the front is
in addition to the existing elevation so
addition along with a side extension as
well so the building has been altered to
the front elevation and you're safe from
the conservation officers comments as
well at whilst whilst the front
elevation is considered to be of some
significance
it's it's
and not particularly unique and it's a
design that's quite common within sanity
of building the this design with they
slide in such windows then this is the
side elevations lips once around to get
Road the existing side and again at the
view of it so this is considered to be
the most significant elevation of the
building so you can see the fact there's
a lot of work and more brickwork within
this elevation and you can see
advertising material on the slide
innovation and low level you can see the
Flint brick wall which was an old
boundary wall run along the edge of the
site so within the heritage statement
this this walls because it's been the
most significant element and the oldest
element of the building and so that some
weight is given to to the significance
of this this innovation they're moving
around to the rear elevation and to the
existing side elevation this was a photo
showing showing this so again you can
see the side elevation of the rear
section on the right hand side but again
you see that the building has been
significantly altered there's plastic
cladding within dormers and single-story
side extensions have been added to the
property so from this view the level of
significance significantly dropped and
is not contribute to the significance of
the building and then this is looking at
the existing floor plans so part of the
when looking at the significance the
building it's partly to do with the
building itself but also the the social
history of the building so the property
has been on the site but in this
condition for at least 200 years and so
there's obviously some local
significance for residents in terms of
the fact there has been a public house
on this site and and the way in which
this has developed over time and now
when looking at the actual building and
the fact it is a community facility as a
public house we have had information
submitted looking at the viability of
the continued use of the building as a
public house the building has been
marketed for at least seven months
I'm a reasonable price for the community
facility and whilst there's been
overtime has been a number of different
landlords and the building has been
significantly refurbished price the last
the more recent marketing and still it's
not considered that the public houses
has been viable and traders has reduced
from the evidence submitted and and
that's the reason that for which the
property has been marketed and over
those seven months has been no interest
from someone taking it on as a public
house or for any other community
facility so you can see from the floor
plans and that is not a significantly
large space at ground floor level and
it's broken up with different rooms the
rear section of the site pays on
different levels so you can see that
there's a steps that go from the front
to the rear so there's a basement area
and then a mid ground between ground and
first of all level so the rear section
is on a different level to the front
section the front section is also broken
up with different internal walls and
there's the black area that you can see
on the right hand side is a fire and a
fireplace so this breaks up that space
as well with the right-hand side being
and separated off from the main space so
it's a it's quite awkward shape to to be
able to to reuse as a non port is not
particularly flexible because of these
different spaces and on different levels
and then this is just showing the first
floor elevation as it is so at the
moment there's residential accommodation
of first floor level above the public
house in the form of a two bit flat so
in terms of the proposal that the in
terms of rigor the significance the fact
that has been a public house on the site
for a long time it does add local
significance to the property
however as that information is has
that's been provided it shows that as
it's not particularly viable to continue
the use as a public house and therefore
that significance as a public house will
be lost through the fact that the
building can no longer continue is at
use um so alternative development has
therefore being proposed as part of
of this application the proposal was for
the erection of two three-story
buildings which contain ten two bit
flats to one bed flats and 2/3 bed Mason
s so you can see within the site there's
block a which is on the left and block B
which is on the right and you can see
that there's a vehicle access has been
provided over on the left-hand side it's
a new access on surrounds Gate road
which will access the parking spaces so
in terms of the design and the proposal
is looking at this three-story building
which is mainly two stories that with
accommodation within the roof space
again when looking at the significance
of the existing building with the sucide
innovation and one of the comment the
comment that was made by the
conservation officer is that because
only a very small element element of the
building to be of significance mainly
being that slide innovation it's not
considered it's enough to make it worthy
to retain the building as a whole
however the reuse of that wall or
materials from that wall into the
proposed development could help to
integrate this into the into the area
and record the history of the site so
you can see from this one innovation
that towards the center of the bays
reclaimed
think work is proposed to be use which
would be from that side of evasion so in
terms of the design is quite traditional
with two storey bays within these gable
projections on either side and then done
within the roof space it will be using
brick the reclaimed think work and
cladding and black state roof this is
the side elevations of block a sand
block on the left you can see on the
left hand side is the innovation face in
the neighboring properties and on the
right hand side is facing the other
block and you can see that the rear
section drops down in height which
reduces the scale of the development
then this is the rear elevation of the
proposal with again you can see the rear
section
dropped down so the Scout of the
development reduced and then it's the
floor plans of the proposal again so
this is showing the three bed flat
within the roof space all of the units
meet the national space standards so now
looking onto block B on the on the right
it's a very similar design again you can
see the two projecting bays and again
the reuse of the reclaimed print work
and again the side elevations so the the
elevation on the right is facing the
adjacent development that's recently
been constructed and then again the rear
elevation and the floor plans so in
terms of how it sits within the street
and you can see it on the right hand
side of the screen you can see the the
adjacent development which was three
storey in Heights and but you can also
see that looking at the ground level the
adjacent moments on a lower ground level
than the proposed development and the
proposed development is adjacent to two
storey houses in Farley Road so in terms
of looking at the height of it the ease
level seeks to follow these level of the
properties in Farley Road with just
accommodation within the roof space you
can see there's large spaces between the
sided ovation of block a and the
neighboring property and between the
development and to the right hand side
as well so it's considered it's it's
well in terms of passenger fellerman and
I'm spacing between between the
development again it's just section
showing through the development so the
application has been amended during its
submission to provide the rear section
dropped down in order to reduce the
overall scale of the development it's 22
meters deep so it was considered that a
reduction in the rear was needed in
order for the better appear supported up
to main the main front section so this
shows the drop in level so the rear
sections 1.5 meters lower than the front
section and again this is another
sections through and then this is taken
at the rear of the slide so these are
the rip the rear lovage section so you
can see how the ground level of the
lower sections and relate to the
neighboring ground
also on the left is the neighboring rear
gardens you can see how that's dropped
in terms of ridiculously impact on the
neighbors there's a distance of 19
metres from the sighted ovation of block
a to the rear end patient of the nearest
neighbor so that would not normally
could be considered an acceptable
distance for over licking so through an
application again the you can see here
the neighbor of properties appear quite
close they've got quite shallow gardens
and and they would be overlooked from
any unclear grace side windows so
through the application again the sided
relation has been amended so this is the
innovation facing those neighbors in the
front section an Oriole window is
proposed whether the window would look
onto the road along with a high-level
window and then the windows in the rear
section at first four level would all be
obscured raised and fixture along with
the dormer windows as well in order to
prevent any overlooking on those
neighbors so in terms of outlook and and
light you can see there's a significant
distance to any of the neighbors to
prevent any impact on on light and
outlook and in terms of the impacts on
the adjacent development there's again
there's a significant distance with no
direct overlooking and there's no side
windows in the neighboring development
so there won't be any any window to
window overlooking between them to the
rear of the site and the properties in
Farley Road have very deep garden so any
rear windows within the development
would be based on the far end of the
neighboring gardens so again there's no
direct overlooking of their private
mmunity space in terms of looking at the
highway impacts as mentioned before the
existing accesses is being made
redundant and being moved back to a
footpath and the new access being crated
to the left-hand side of the site with
an adequate visibility sprays highways
have raised no objections to the
proposal 16 parking spaces are being
proposed including to Vista parking
spaces allowing for one space per unit
plus the Vista parking spaces and that
this would include some electric vehicle
charging spaces as well in terms of the
landscaping and as you saw from the
photos there some mature trees along the
rear boundary of the site
all of the mature trees within the site
are to be retained and you can see these
retained through this floorplan so the
area is outlined in green are the retain
trees there's a few trees that are to be
removed you can see them outlined in red
and these are much smaller trees within
a site that don't offer as much amenity
value and therefore the loss of these
trees is not suited to be of concern and
but the retention of the larger trees is
certainly supported through the scheme
the proposal also includes additional
planting as you can see in the in the
corners of the site with new trees and
there's a large grass area to the rear
and side which would provide the
immunity space for the units and would
also link in with a neighboring
development so there won't be any
boundary tremor between the two but
there would be actual shared immediate
space between the two sides for the
occupiers of the development there'd be
refuge storage towards the front of the
site so to the front outlined in green
on this plan is is the refuge storage
area and thus local storage area is
outlined in in purple and that would be
located to the rear so it's a balanced
application so there are quite a few
concerns regarding the loss of the
existing building including those from
the Civic Society and the number of
residents as mentioned the main
significance of the building is
considered to be the elevation that
fronts the road sorry I'll just skip
back to the faces again so sorry that
elevation so so this elevation is
considered to be of the most significant
of the entire building but I visited the
site where the conservation areas looked
inside this there's nothing of any value
within the building itself so it's not
it's not where they've been listed
especially given the number of
alterations have been made to the
building and so while says there's local
significance from the social history of
a building of the site the fact that
it's not viable to continue as a public
house is a relevant point because you
this this user can't continue any longer
so overall whilst it is except that is
an undesignated heritage asset and the
scale of the loss will be significant
through its demolition
the significance the building is limited
to just this one innovation and
therefore when considering this against
the benefits of the Houser scheme which
will be on a windfall site and will
therefore contribute to the council's
housing need the benefits from miss
housing fed an opposite of outweigh the
harm from the loss of of this building
and therefore it's acceptable in terms
of their the heads of terms and a number
of contributions are proposed in the
development which the agent has agreed
to and you can see in the report these
he sets out to the rear of the port end
of the book so we're just waiting for
the labor agreement to be submitted to
secure these and subject to the
submission of this it's the application
is recommended for approval thank you
thank you very much chairman I move that
the officer is recommendation for give
Ferg's second second thank you I'm not
sure who did that but I am no counselor
comic cook anyway is that counsel yes s
key okay thank you very much members and
I open it to you first on my list if I
don't come back to you on the side panel
I am making notes of those who wish to
speak so you you're not being ignored
Thank You councillor Albin yes thank you
chair and I called this application in
what seems like a lifetime ago now
obviously somehow some months ago and
the the reason I called it in was
because of the impacts of the current
building within the street seat as as
has been said it's been there
approximately 200 years and I think it
would probably either bill
of the similar public house prior to
their and I don't wish to get melancholy
about the building itself however I find
that the agents statement or the
applicants statement that they've been
advertising it for seven months and
nobody's wanted it
well I there's been a building site next
to it for a year or so
taking place so probably anybody would
look at it wouldn't want to look it
wouldn't want to have it anyway because
there's a building site next to it I
also concerned about the possible over
development of this site it just seems
that there's a hell of a lot of there's
a hell of a lot of dwelling and skullet
governing cities to this site and also
I'm not swallowing the issue raised
again by all you know we've got we've
got NHS workers and livid here it's
across the road edited a day I'm not
having there either I think overall if
there was no building if the pub wasn't
wasn't there I would happily support
this application chair although I still
think it's crammed in and but I I'm
afraid that I have to side with the
retention of the the building of course
a building that's been there as long as
long as this it will get altered it will
get changed over like like loads of
buildings though no houses though get
extensions excessive etcetera etcetera
there is a lot of Merit in in this
building within the street scene so I'm
finding it very difficult to side with
the officers request that we should
approve this anyway that's that's all I
wish to say at present Thank You chair
Thank You councillor Albarn there
councillor to obey that Thank You chair
yes and I think it's very sad that this
building
after 200 years has met the end of its
useful life however a lot of it has
already been altered
I think the homes are very badly needed
and I think that the site is quite
sensitively planned especially
maintaining the reclaimed Flint yes
there's some loss of trees but but again
the mature trees are being being
maintained and and I think at some point
homes for people have to take precedence
I feel for those reasons that I will
probably like to support this
application thank you chair thank you
can serve a third councilor keen thank
you chair my concern is around the
traffic and the parking it may meet
minimum recommendations but there's
going to be more cars than one per unit
and there's already quite a lot of
congestion around the side roads around
that area it's also I know a new access
is being created but it goes on to the
very fast-flowing Ramsgate Road with the
forty mile per hour speed limit and I
just wonder about the safety of that and
the safety of people crossing the road
more people sort of using the crossing
to get across to the bus stop which I
understand is going to be moved can we
be told where the bus stop would be
moved to Thank You Emma can you come
back on that that was in a comment from
one of the objectors so it may not be
correct but that was where I read it
I mean looking at the photos out - there
is a bus stop over between the access
and what appears to be between the two
accesses so yes bustle does appear to be
there I haven't seen any comments from
highways on the bus stop and relocation
I mean I guess if it was needed that
would take place and highways would
would relocate it to a safer position
but they've certainly not objected to
the application on any highway safety
grounds the access has been provided
with I think the visibility sprays and
91 metres by 2.4 meters so it's quite a
lot of on visibility space from the
access point and therefore they've not
raise any objections to that and also
they've had to compare the traffic into
the site from the existing puppy yes and
compare that to the proposed flat use
and I'll see ya - pop use you could have
quite a lot of vehicles as well that
would be accessing that so Inc when
comparing the two there's going to be a
significant impacts on on highway safety
from that but yes in terms of the bus
stop I wasn't actually where that was
moving but if it is then that would just
have to happen up through a separate
traffic regulation order potentially
okay thank you and thank you Emma
councillor Garber thank you
yeah just wanted to make a couple of
comments on the on what we've heard one
I I concur with council Albarn around
around the cramped krampus of the houses
accommodations being built on what is
here what is another windfall housing
site we do think we building up quite a
large number will windfall housing sites
are those not identified in the local
plan we're almost going to end up with
more unnecessary housing windfall
housing sites than we we have in the
plan
the other point I wanted to make was
around the trees yes it would be good
that we keep in the far
mature trees and on that it would be it
would be good if we could put a
condition on that these are going
forward then covered by TP o--'s so that
if there was a for going forward any of
the new residents wanted to do
unnecessary work and move them they
weren't going to be able to and the
other point is on condition 27 which
which relates to the landscape in and
mentions any trees or plants within a
period of five years from the quarry so
the development die will be the place
I'd like it there to be to be a bit
firmer about making sure they don't die
and don't need to be replaced because we
have got a very poor tract they're
called in Thanet of letting developers
get away we can't in trees and they're
just leaving them to die and there's
there are many like that within my ward
on concert enough so I think we need to
move take this opportunity to make sure
that that it's not just planting trees
it's looking after them for five years
I'm making sure they thrive so they're
there more points maybe if that
condition could be firmed up a bit thank
you Thank You councillor Hart page I
must say I'm in favor and against this
proposal I mean I think it's a shame to
leave the office as that's what I said
but I think he's had his day I am
concerned by the fact that it's an
overdeveloped site in my opinion there's
not enough parking
everybody needs two parking spaces who's
going to have a place there because
there's no parking anywhere down the
side roads for overspill they're going
to sit on the main road then and I think
there's going to be a an issue for
safety and I also agree with counsel
gone about the trees if they're going to
keep the mature trees they should be TP
owed and they've got to make sure that
if they're working around that they put
surface matting down
don't damage the roads otherwise they
will kill the trees so I think that's
something that needs to be investigated
as well before we agree this to be fair
I think you can come to curry Thank You
chair for me there are two main issues
with regards to retaining the building
what could this building be used for in
the future if it wasn't taken up as a
public in which he's likely and also the
the diagonal position of the building
means any adjoining development would be
very difficult I would be worried as
well of this building would end up as a
white elephant Thank You chair I think
of that council career counselor right I
agree with I'm the I'm the I'm between
the devil and the deep blue sea on this
one I realized that we have got a need
for more housing I find it hard to
believe that a good architect couldn't
incorporate the the exterior of the pub
and converts it rather than demolish it
to say that it's going to be too much
trouble for me using an excuse and if it
would also Emma said that to leave the
pub in situ would mean that they'd be
compromised with their number of flats
well I think leaving it there would be a
compliment with be the compromise
because everybody would be happy we
would get some new houses or new flats
but we'd also retain the exterior of a
really lovely property Thank You counsel
Casa comment cook Thank You chair
it just seems to me that we are not all
building there that has been said by
people that it's not viable for
financially for convert conversion
there's if this does not get approved
today what happens to that building left
to rot this we hear people saying
constantly lovely old building but how
long will it be lovely it's kind of rot
people is not financially viable from
tegami
and convert that so personally I think
if the locals felt that they did morning
note down with perhaps surely usually a
lot more when it was a pub they I
personally will be supporting the
officers recommendation Thank You chair
Thank You Council debate for you wish to
come back
Thank You chair yes I totally agree with
counselor Curry's comments the position
of the the pub across the site would
make any building around it very very
difficult and as for renovating it if
it's going to be changed so much it's it
the old building is lost anyway I really
feel that that argument falls flat and I
think that I totally support the
officers recommendation to supply these
houses which we so badly needed need
thank you Kay thank you for that
councillor Scott yeah I mean just a
quick words having listened to the
officers and fellow councillor sir I
mean for myself it's considered a
brownfield site so I mean these my
opinions should be encouraged especially
over sort of greenfield sites I can
obviously understand sympathize with
people when it comes to obviously
retaining heritage below
I mean we've got a look on sort of
economically if the the pub wasn't
viable then and it's sat there for seven
months I mean when do we sort of give
this say you know how long's a piece of
string what's the acceptable term to
leave that as a commercial premises for
someone to pick it up two years three
years four years five years down the
line and if no one's going to make use
of it or if anyone's going to sort of
inherit it so to speak then we just have
an empty property and sooner or later
the new generation will be like okay
well why do we have that there so yeah I
mean you know having weighed this rule
out it's certainly a difficult decision
but you know I've come to my decision
and I feel I have decide in the offices
with this one so thank you thank you
Scott Council Gamow you wish to come by
thing yeah just just quickly I'll get
back to the trees but would it be
possible for mr. Livingstone Aldi or the
others to state that we can put put TPI
on those mature trees there please and
and beef up condition 27 to make sure
all new trees planted are looked after
so they do survive and thrive please
Thanks now I'll come to Emma but whether
Ian would like to answer that mo do you
wish to take that on the quality of the
trees more pressure being put on the
trees through through the development of
the site so that is something we can
look at doing and in terms of the
protection of on going maintenance of
new tree planting and I think that's
something our tree officer is aware of I
think he's been to some sites recently
that have been developed where the trees
have been planted and there have been
problems I think he's very much aware of
it he's keen to make sure that going
into the future that we do make sure
that sites where there's been tree
planting it is maintained and we do make
sure it survives
Thank You Emma I can't see any other
speakers if I have missed anybody out
they could state no Thank You members
okay I'm going to put this officers
recommendation to you which is for
deferral as usual if you could say when
I call your name out for against or
abstain Thank You councillor comment
cook for cancer oven against counts of a
fit for councillor curry for councillor
Duckworth for Nance LaDonna finding
Thank You councillor Hart against Cal so
keen against I don't think we have
councillor more correct me if I'm wrong
Patmore
no okay councillor assess key for
councillor Scott for councillor Taylor
I'm not sure if he's arrived no
counselor right abstain myself I'm for
my wor see how Emily's counted up Thank
You members that emotion has been
carried thank you for that very
interesting as well that concludes
public speaking for this meeting I will
now call upon the clerk to read out the
remaining planning applications if a
member wishes to reserve an application
will they please call out as she reads
Emily how would you yes please
councillor gonna be yes please see the
David Copperfield West Road Road
Broadstairs
no not for three for a day
laundry of Pink's corner lodge Brummell
court minister okay that CMD that
haven't been reserved okay
can I have a proposal to move these
applications are noted propose and
second please
I'm second chair and do you agree agreed
agreed
great things as rising thank you rights
moving back to item for a my grass you
officer please to the details this is
the David Copperfield Thank You chair
I'll just present my screen I can't
whistle either so the application site
is outlined in red members will recall
we had the application to change the use
of this building a few committees ago
this application is for adverts and
consent for the erection of a totem sign
that is six point five meters high to
serve the new premises so as the
Americans know application events
iterations are the impact on amenity and
also the impact on public safety so the
site is are an aerial image in in this
area here and so in terms of where the
totem sign is to be located it's to be
located between the the the new some
McDonald's restaurant and the KFC
directly adjacent to the road so if you
can see the area of parking in in this
area here a
it is the if this is the small cross
that's that's located in this area here
where the totem sign would be so this is
an image looking at the building as it
is now so we're the sort of hedging and
small small growth is in this area here
would be where the totem sign is you can
see if you look further down the road
the remnants of the previous sign that
serves the David Copperfield which was
in sitio and if I click onto the next
image it will show you it's a little bit
clearer so previously there was a a
similar sort of totem sign that was so
further closer to the building which was
a 4.5 meters high in that location then
looking back towards the the proposed
site so you can see again the remnants
of the David Copperfield Harvester sign
and so the totem son would be around
about where this lamppost is here this
is a closer in view showing some of the
street furniture that you have at the
KFC so this is an existing sign that's
in front of the KFC and just this is
another view of that sign and then
there's also a totem sign that serves as
de which is on the other corner of the
roundabout so this is the design of the
sign it's as mentioned 6.5 meters high
so it's higher than the previous sign
that was on on the site by by a couple
of metres the M is to be illuminated as
part of the proposal the the intensity
of the light was reduced during the
course of the application from 600
candelas per square meter to 400 candles
per meter square and the report talks
about the the impact of the illumination
on the area so officers consider that
the signage would be in a commercial
location and other totem signs are off
found in the area and the scans IDs
considered to be appropriate given its
location it's it's not considered to be
overly bright following the reduction in
in the intensity of the light and
therefore whilst this site is adjoining
the green wedge it is considered
appropriate for this this sort of part
of the the suburban landscape because
you do have quite a few sources and
light in and around there including in
the lights of the car park in ASDA as
well as the illumination you have on the
signs of the premises around there it's
not an intrinsically dark landscape and
therefore we don't consider that there
is a significant harm from the
illumination that because which would
just be restricted to the M itself
so overall the application is is
recommended for approval thank you thank
you mr. Livingston councillor Ghana
sorry sorry I do recommend the offices
recommendation could I have a seconder
please
our second it mr. chairman thank you
right camps Madonna thank you thank you
I mean I I told this and the other two
on the agenda in the same time as I
called the one that we discussed four
weeks ago the main one around the round
opening the McDonald's restaurant
tomorrow
obviously I accept the decision that's
been made about about the McDonald's
restaurant four weeks ago and that's now
going ahead
sorry no work has started up there
already on the construction work I
wanted to make a couple of points on
behalf of local residents
I know in the report is noted that there
were no objections raised against this
application when in fact they're not
enough of objections were raised
relating to the lighting and signage but
they all logged against the recomment
the main applique
which there were 17 letters of objection
and then there were also a petition saw
him around and 36 people opposing this
and one of the one of the objections was
relating to the signage the I'm not
really sure that on behalf of my
residents that regard has been paid to
the surrounding area this isn't in it in
with the local residents on oh six and a
half meters high is quite a lot higher
than the previous one which was four and
a half meters and I know there's no note
made the the harvester had planning
permission for a four and a half meter
sign which I don't think actually went
ahead in in the end but this is six and
a half big decide and I do believe that
it is a it is out of keeping with the
area and while the building is going to
be going ahead I think this one
exacerbates the adverse impact of the
character and appearance of the area so
I'm obviously open to persuasion on that
but as it stands I don't think this is
six and a half meter totem pole should
be allowed thank you thank you house
garma councillor Albin
yes Thank You chair it's a question
really - yeah I just wanted to know this
does sound rather high six six and a
half meters is that do we have any
others within the area those that are as
high as that is this common in other
words mr. Louison Thank You chair so as
mentioned by Costigan and and in the
report that the signage that was there
was was was four and a half meters so
that that 2015 application to my
understanding was was implemented with
regards to again the remnants and I was
present my screen again just to show you
those images
so so the the the image which is looking
towards the KFC so this is the four and
a half meter signage that was in place
you can see the frame of it so it's two
meters on top so it's not as high as the
LAT the top of the actual lamp that's
that's present there so it's not the
full height so it's still below the
street furniture that's there and in
terms of comparables this is an image
that shows of the height of the of the
KFC signage we don't have the precise
details of the height of that signage
but you can see that actually that sign
is comparable to the actual height of
the building itself if I showed you a
different perspective which is that one
that does not represent how high it is
which is why this is the image that
actually shows that the two as a
perspective and those that are familiar
with the site also know that that that
is quite high sign given that the
building itself is is almost one and a
half stories in height so we are pushing
closer to 5 meters to 6 meters so whilst
the Asda sign if we go to that one
is again it's it's that one is higher
than the four and a half meters but he's
only just a little behind that so we're
still looking at signs that are a
roundabout but not necessarily certainly
not over six and a half meters but
therefore the important point is the
context to which that sign the proposed
sign would sit because the backdrop off
the signage are the buildings themselves
and the height will not exceed the
building which is in situ here on the
site obviously it's a full two storey
building it's not considered that the
sign it would be dominant in relation to
the environment around there and also in
terms of the the width of the sign for
example it's it's a relatively
unobtrusive design in terms of what it's
looked like it's broken up by the
different panels so it's not going to
appear as a singular mass and the only
actual the only bit that is illuminated
is the top M so we don't think on that
basis that it's that the height in
itself would would contribute towards I
suppose a a justified refusal I think
there's this there's enough here to
suggest that it because of the way it's
been designed and its location that it
wouldn't result in an obtrusive impact
on the character appearance of the area
thank you back to you yes councilman yes
just to say on that thank you very very
much
on that basis and on the basis that
they've already reduced the illumination
of it a non-core heaviness to support
this chair thank you Thank You
councillor Hart
you know my question was exactly near
enough the same as councillor Albans to
be honest
my only concern really I mean I
understand what Ian saying and I do
agree the one central quite like said I
think the problem we get is that
everybody's going to be competing for a
taller and taller sign and then we're
going to end up with this situation that
you have something that's 20 storeys
tall that says welcome to Thanet or
whatever it does I mean at the end of
the day I think we should have a limit
to height and you know we don't want
things that are going to take over and
show and I think we have to have an
overall decision from the council
planning officers as to what the maximum
height will be anywhere so that we have
a basis for which to work from because I
think everybody's just going to set
their sights a bit big I want to be
bigger than them and I think that needs
to be put into place really so we don't
have this argument thank you very much
council accounts too right mr. chair
it's a pity that you we haven't got a
picture just a little bit further round
the round back because I think the
biggest impact is this is the as design
and I've got no I've got any compared to
some of the older McDonald's
eliminations this actually looks a lot
better so I've got no objections at all
Thank You councillor Banford
Thank You chair yes I mean as as in
said this is a commercial site
the sign is is very tall but it isn't
overbearing in design and personally I
have no objection to this and I'll
support you thank you thank you
and you wanted to come back yes if I may
check just about the just with regards
to the point the counselor Hart was
making about you know the sort of the
council's view with regards to
advertisements it is something that's
this usually managed through the
policymaking side of the planning
process and in years gone by there was
supplementary planning guidance
specifically about adverts that was
looked at what what we don't have in the
district is areas of special invertible
control which is something that
theoretically could come through the
plan making process which restricts down
what is permitted without adverts mon
consent and and that is something that
can be looked at but those those
elements are looked at through the plan
making process so it would be sort part
of potentially the local plan review if
if members wants to raise it through
through those those channels Thank You
councillor recess key yeah just a quick
observation in my travels around the
world I've seen a lot bigger end signs
around the place and this one does seem
quite sir in keeping with the area as
this KFC announced the signs around I
don't think the two meters is that much
of a problem I think if I'm not mistaken
it's a slight slope down there so I'm
not convinced it's going to be that much
bigger or taller than the other signs if
you even out the landscape so yes I will
be supporting it thank you Thank You
councillor SVA I understand that counsel
more has just joined us but on this
occasion I cannot allow counsel more to
vote so that there's no other speakers I
put this to the vote once again for
against or abstain and as usual your
name
I will fall out counselor comical before
counselor Albin full cancer Banford for
councillor curry for how's that berth
full counts the Ghana against councillor
heart for aim for councillor is s key or
councillor Scott abstain counter Taylor
is with us still cancer rights for and
myself at for that sounds how it is
carried that motion is carry Thank You
Emily
moving on to item 4b again the day the
copper toward could I ask the officer
please to in the report thank him I will
just share my screen so it is the the
same the same site but this application
concerns the proposed facie signs
they're actually situated on the
building itself so there are five
internally eliminated signs that are
proposed are on this building I will
just so the main elevations the building
to look at are this elevation that
fronts westward Road then this is the
angled view of of that same elevation
and then this is the full-on front view
of that so this building slightly
changing as part of the previously
approved application and to remove
certain elements of it but you'll see
what the the facade would look like with
the adverts on it and then it's the the
other elevation that phases into the
slow car park access area which is the
other entrance to the building where
there are there are signs that are
proposed within this scheme
so the elevation that we were just
looking at is the one that faces the the
right of the image that you're looking
at and then the front elevation is the
one as you can see that faces the road
so if we look at the front elevation of
the building so what's proposed here are
two M logos one above the actual door
itself and then one in the apex of the
roof with some of the width then
McDonald's in the signage that's that's
present on the screen as you can see so
amendments were sought through this
application to reduce the scale of the
the wording so if I click to the next
slide you'll see that originally it was
proposed with with larger large writing
and and it was a a similar application
to the previous one in the sense that it
was proposed at 600 candles per meter
squared so as part of this application
the the actual size of the wording has
decreased and the intensity of the light
has also decreased on the been on the
elevation that we saw previously there
is larger signage writing because you're
facing into the access road so it's not
considered to cause harm for the primary
frontage of the premises and then a
slightly larger M above the other door
that's being proposed there so that's
just the other elevation to drive see so
in terms the detail of those signs it's
a case that the the full face of those
letters would be illuminated and then
the illumination of the arch itself as
well so overall it's the same
considerations for members the impact on
amenity is the primary consideration
this one follows on from the previous
application in the sense of the building
previously did have signage on it when
it was the harvester this this signage
has been appropriately designed
following the amendments in terms of
fitting in with the building so it
doesn't dominate the the primary and
principal elevations of the property
and as outlined in the report it's
considered that the location is is you
know is appropriate for this type of
illumination and this intensity of
illumination given the fact that the
signs have been reduced in size it's not
in our view going to have a significant
or adverse impact on the landscape from
from the way that it's been put forward
and so therefore it's it's recommended
for approval thank thank you ii and i
move that the officers recommendation is
adopted could I have a seconder please I
can be Thank You councillor Gama you
wanted to speak on this one yes please I
have similar similar concerns about
these signs I had on the previous one
have more particular concerns are on
sign 17 and 18 which aren't the ones
facing the vote but they're the ones on
the side of the booth facing towards
Asda but that will also of course when
lit up especially at night be visible by
from the residence houses and gardens
and back onto the site because all right
you'll probably remember when we when we
discussed and and this was approved for
the main the main application two
meetings ago we in our wisdom increased
the height of a fence between the
residents and the McDonald's from 2.4
meters to 3 meters and now while that
might have might help with the odors and
the traffic fumes from the Q queuing
traffic to place their orders at the
McDonald's I don't think that's going to
help with the visuality of the signs on
top of the roof from the residence so I
do believe that this may have an adverse
effect on the residential amenity and
character of surrounding areas
especially for those local residents
after I was sitting there their garden
or lay
they're paired at night looking out
their windows at these black glaring
glaring through of them and so that's
why I mind my main concern is around
though those two sides thank you thank
you house Tigana I can't see any other
speakers so I'm going to put this to
yourselves members once again this is
for approval and again if you would say
for against and abstain a grateful
Ian before we do that hang on and you
wish to speak Thank You Chester
apologies for coming in a little bit
like that I just if it's worth for the
benefit and just to come back on cancer
the gharanas point just to I hope
alleviate some concerns with regards the
impact on neighbors um what what we've
looked at specifically on this is about
the intensity of the light so the
relationship with the neighboring
properties is that the the elevation in
question with with the sort of larger
signage is is the one that's on the
right-hand side of the building so
there's no direct views that any of the
neighbors have to the signs it's it's
angled views there in our view in the
context of the overall lighting that's
present in the vicinity but also in
terms of the intensity of the light
reducing to 400 candelas per meter
square that that is a low intensity and
to give the sort of comparison that's
that's generally around the same if not
less than a than an HD television so
it's not it's not considered that there
would be a significant impact from from
glare to to impact on neighboring
properties thank you thank you and that
answers cows Tagami
okay if we go back to yourselves say
officers recommendation is for approval
okay oh through your names you could say
yes so for gain or abstain I'm a
councillor Gordon cook for
cancer Albin four counts of a third for
cancer curry for council up worth of the
garner against counselor counselor keen
for counselor more you heard the debate
they are if you're there no I move on
counts to recess key or counselor
Scott's abstain answer right before and
myself for and I think that he's hairy
Thank You members
before we close the meeting members I
slipped up and did it before
unfortunately but very simple there was
items agreed without debate which was I
some agenda item for see I have a
proposer that that is correct yes
second second egg very rude
thank you very well that concludes this
afternoon meeting when we Tim thank you
very much your attendance and comments
watch out for the Thunder promise that
all men together and they're always